simone biles has long soared above the
rest of the world
but now she occupies even more rarefied
space
withdrawing from olympic competition not
for a physical injury but she says to
protect her mental health
dominique dawes as the first
african-american woman to win olympic
gold in gymnastics
knows all about the pressure of carrying
the hopes not just of a country
but a community there's a great deal of
pressure that i felt
leading up to the 1996 olympic games and
prior to marching out i had an emotional
breakdown
do you think this is a game-changing
moment for sport
i think this is definitely a
game-changing moment for the sport
sports in general i think definitely for
the sport of gymnastics that
simone biles has made a decision that is
best for her that she listened to her
inner voice which is something that many
gymnasts have shut off because we're
told that we
don't have a say biles had considered
quitting altogether after winning four
golds at the rio olympics
she came back not just to fight for more
medals but she says to fight for the
future of her sport
she is a survivor of sexual abuse by
larry nassar
the usa team doctor now serving a life
sentence for his crimes
i knew him for 10 years of my childhood
i saw him as a friend he was someone
that many athletes trusted
and they were victims and simone being
one of them she's the only
victim of larry nassar that is currently
on the floor at the olympic games
and that really speaks volumes on the
vault where she's reigning olympic
champion
biles is usually both spectacular and
solid
but in tokyo she was clearly struggling
seasoned gymnastics watchers recognized
it as the twisties
a kind of mental block that might be
called the yips in other sports
but in gymnastics it strikes while an
athlete is already in the air
it's it's truly is a gymnast kryptonite
you're not shooting a basketball you're
not
you're not just running you're doing a
double flip with triple twist
and if you get lost during that skill
there's a good chance
you're gonna shatter your legs you could
break your back you could land on your
head
biles has now withdrawn from the
individual all-around event at the
olympics
it's increasingly likely the world won't
witness her genius again in tokyo
but the face of this games has still
ignited a long overdue conversation
perhaps simone biles's legacy is not
just about being the greatest ever
gymnast
but transforming the way sport will
treat its future stars
and their mental health martha kellner
sky news
good job well in the last few hours
simone has in fact been tweeting
at her 1.5 million followers this is
what she
had to say the outpouring of love and
support i've received has
made me realize i'm more than my
accomplishments and gymnastics
which i never truly believed before